I don't like it when people tell me what
to do like you should buy health care or
don't carry a concealed weapon into this
park or hey that leather jacket is way
too small for you I can make my own
decisions listen do I think we should
streamline the income tax by
establishing just two brackets chat
standard deductions are boom Shakalaka
who has time to itemize anything between
ironically riding a tricycle two
ping-pong league and having non vaginal
intercourse with girls they met at
Christian summer can get real government
I'm a Republican because I believe you
don't get jobs giving handouts you get
out by giving hand jobs wait